Seguramente, cuando piensan
en una computadora, imaginan algo así.
Pero déjenme decirles que estamos rodeados
de muchas otras computadoras,
pero no las vemos.
Lavarropas, ascensores,
equipos médicos, autos.
Todos tienen algún tipo
de inteligencia electrónica,
un cerebro al que llamamos computadora.
Por ejemplo, en un lavarropas.
De alguna manera, nosotros
lo programamos para que cargue agua
para que haga un lavado, haga un enjuague.
vuelva a cargar agua, lavado,
enjuague, centrifugado.
Esto lo hace un programa que está adentro
del lavarropas en una computadora.
En un ascensor, según en qué piso estamos,
qué botón tocamos o si estamos
subiendo o bajando,
hay una computadora que decide
qué es lo que tiene que hacer.
Y en algún sentido,
la computadora del ascensor
y del lavarropas son parecidas.
Y hay otras computadoras
que tienen que ser más robustas
como por ejemplo en un equipo médico,
donde está en juego
la vida de una persona,
o en un semáforo, que si tiene
que dar una luz roja
y de pronto da una luz verde,
puede causar un accidente.
O el sistema electrónico
de frenos de un auto.
O hay casos como por ejemplo
en un equipo petrolero
quizás está horas e incluso días
de viaje de la ciudad más cercana,
y entonces no puede fallar
porque no pueden repararlo todo el tiempo.
Y la pregunta es:
¿quién diseña estas computadoras?
¿Quién las fabrica? ¿Quién las programa?
Y la verdad es que en nuestro país
muchas veces dependemos de computadoras
que son fabricadas en el exterior,
son importadas.
O sea, dependemos de otros.
Y esto hace que muchas empresas argentinas
desean no utilizar electrónica
cuando podrían utilizarla para mejorar
sus productos o sus procesos productivos.
O hay otras que deciden seguir utilizando
sus desarrollos viejos, obsoletos.
Y hay algunas que optan por usar
electrónica importada y dependen de otros.
Son muy pocas las que se animan
a desarrollar sus propias
soluciones electrónicas.
Con un grupo de gente
hace un poco menos de un año
nos pusimos de acuerdo para tratar
de revertir esta situación,
para ayudar a las empresas,
a las pequeñas y medianas
empresas de nuestro país.
Y ustedes pensarán que somos todos
premios Nobel o expertos de la NASA,
pero no.
Déjenme decirles que somos
estudiantes, ingenieros,
empresarios, comunicadores, diseñadores.
Que estamos distribuidos por todo el país.
Eso implica que hay gente
que tiene distinta forma de vida.
Y somos muy jóvenes.
La edad de promedio es
de más o menos treinta años.
Me hubiese gustado poner una foto
donde puedan ver a todo el grupo
decenas y decenas de personas,
pero la verdad es que no tengo.
Porque hay mucha de esta gente
que nunca se vio en su vida.
Quizás nunca se conozcan,
quizás nunca se vean,
porque trabajan por Internet, compartiendo
archivos por e-mail, por Skype.
Y sin embargo así, vamos trabajando.
Y entre todos hicimos la CIA o CIAA
la Computadora Industrial
Abierta Argentina,
que es la que tengo acá en mi mano.
"Computadora" ya les dije por qué,
"industrial" ya les dije también.
Y "abierta", ¿por qué?
Porque toda la documentación,
toda la información de cómo está hecha,
de cómo se hace y demás
está toda publicada en Internet.
Cualquiera la pueda bajar
y la puede utilizar libremente.
Podemos decir
que la CIA no tiene secretos.
(Risas)
¿Y esto qué implica?
Llega por ejemplo una empresa,
si necesita usar una computadora
por ejemplo para un proceso productivo,
puede ir y comprar una
a alguien que la venda
y sabe que no depende de esa persona,
porque el día de mañana
se la puede comprar a un tercero
o la puede hacer ella misma.
O por ejemplo si tiene que hacer
una máquina que lleva una computadora,
puede decir "Bueno,
yo me la fabrico por mi cuenta".
O puede por ejemplo decir
"Yo me bajo la información,
la modifico como quiero, esto es libre"
y hace su propia versión que le sirva
a su propio caso.
Y eso implica que genera trabajo,
que genera riqueza,
valor agregado en nuestro país.
Y existen en el mundo
otras computadoras abiertas,
pero que por lo general están soportadas
por una empresa multinacional que fabrica
los circuitos integrados, los chips.
Y lo hace como una estrategia de marketing
y siempre queda atado
uno al chip de esa empresa.
En cambio, nosotros, como no dependemos
de ninguna empresa multinacional
tenemos distintas versiones
basadas en distintos procesadores,
lo que significa
que somos libres de verdad.
No dependemos de ninguna
empresa en particular.
Pero además, esta computadora,
que tengo acá en mi mano,
es la primera computadora
abierta industrial.
Está pensada desde el comienzo
para ser utilizada
en aplicaciones industriales.
Entonces, ¿qué es esto?
En definitiva son circuitos,
son programas, una plaqueta.
¿Y cómo se hace?
Bueno, viene una persona
y dice "Yo hago esto".
Otro dice "Okey, yo hago aquello";
otro dice "Yo los ayudo".
Mi trabajo en todo esto es coordinar eso.
E incluso hay empresas,
pequeñas empresas argentinas,
que son competidoras
en un determinado nicho,
pero que se dan cuenta
de que si participan y colaboran
una va a vender un poco más,
una va a vender todavía más quizás,
pero todas van a crecer, porque
lo que crece es la industria nacional.
Y para hacer esto, no tenemos
un manual, una receta,
porque es algo que nunca antes
se hizo en ningún lugar del mundo.
Entonces aprendemos a medida que hacemos.
Y esto está basado
en trabajo colaborativo voluntario.
Son personas que no cobran por hacer esto,
que quizá lo hacen a la noche
cuando vuelven del trabajo
a sus casas, o el fin de semana.
O algunos tienen la suerte
que en el trabajo les permiten hacerlo.
Y sin embargo, si sumamos la horas
invertidas en esto,
se llevan invertidos
más de diez millones de pesos.
¿Y dónde se utiliza esto?
Bueno, por ejemplo, se están haciendo
aplicaciones para equipos médicos,
para equipos ferroviarios,
equipos industriales,
para la industria
del petróleo, para el agro.
Y además, algo muy importante
para nosotros,
es que hay una red atrás
de más de 50 facultades
de Ingeniería de todo el país,
que son prácticamente todas las facultades
del país que enseñan electrónica,
que venimos trabajando.
La idea es que a partir del mes
de marzo del año que viene
en todas se empiece a utilizar
esta plataforma para enseñar.
Que es una forma de difundir esto
y además es una forma
de que se lo puedan apropiar todos.
Esto es un sueño.
Es la primera computadora
industrial abierta argentina.
(Aplausos)
(Fin aplausos)
Hay gente que deja su huella
con cosas geniales
como un cuadro, un libro,
música.
Nosotros somos ingenieros.
Nuestra magia, nuestro arte
es hacer cosas concretas,
como esta computadora.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)